gonna ask if how do you not get jealous
because I'm like I would be so jealous
yeah because two of the girls fell in
love with me and it was like a big it
was like it was like non-stop drama I
was trying to basically try what Hugh
Hefner was doing where he was living
with like on the girls next door and it
sounded good in theory but in practice
you know people there's like so much
drama every day about every little thing
so it's like lots of stress lots of BS
like I think the jealous part is like
about like I was okay like living with
the girls but like the part is when you
put a bunch of people together to live
together like the real world kind of
thing it's like it's like those TV shows
like those
um shows you know the people started
like arguing for nothing it's like so
much drama all the time